you can do effective social media in
under 20 minutes a day you sort of get
your thoughts ready you put them into
some kind of social media scheduling
thing and then you just release them at
strategic points over the day uh on a
break later in the day just go on your
phone you see who's interacting who's
engaging who's not make a couple of
responses a couple of likes couple of
favorites it doesn't have to be
overwhelming so that's where i would
start and as to which platform here's
what i would do
which one is most native to you my guess
is we got a lot of videographers here
you know a lot of people who love videos
so probably is youtube and tiktok maybe
or instagram reels that would be natural
the other question to ask though is
where's your audience like if you have
an avatar
where are they
welcome back to the think media podcast
my name is heather torres and i am the
host of the show and here we are helping
you grow your influence on youtube and
then turn that influence into a high
income and a high impact online business
we're giving you tips and tools every
single week so make sure you are
subscribed wherever you like to listen
to your podcast we are making this
podcast available everywhere that audio
is available as well as on youtube so if
you've not been to our youtube channel
make sure you subscribe to the think
media podcast youtube channel that's
right we have two different channels so
you can subscribe to both of those to
get all the video uploads that we have
available for you
now i want to thank everyone who has
been a part of this podcast as we've
been growing and this is so awesome that
we get to do part two of the carrie
newhauf series carrie newhoff is one of
our mentors here at think media and
we've actually coined our entire
year to be at your best which is based
off of carrie's newest book at your best
we have gone through uh part one last
week and then additionally sean actually
did some um teachings with our team all
around the theme of at your best so i'll
make sure to link up all of those
additional episodes down in the
description below or wherever you're
listening to podcasts in the show notes
as well but we are in part two of this
interview series where we actually had
carrie come and speak to our leadership
here at think media and last week we
talked all about burnout now this is a
real issue the idea that content
creators ceos and admin assistants are
burning out and so we wanted to help our
team be at their best this year and so
carrie talked about how to go from the
stress cycle into the thrive cycle and
today we're actually jumping into a
different part of carrie's background
and that is is that carrie is also a
content creator along with being an
author and a pastor and a whole resume
of who kerry newhoff is now he is also
creating content on a regular basis but
he's not just creating content and
spending a bunch of time doing it he's a
highly efficient content creator so we
wanted to break that down for you um and
take you behind the scenes on what we
did with our team so today we're going
to be talking about two different pieces
how uh what the difference between deep
work and shallow work is and the other
thing that carrie does so well is his
podcast actually has very high profile
guests so if you want to be able to have
a youtube channel or a show where you
can be bringing on high profile guests
he's going to break down how he was able
to get people like simon cynic rick
warren michael todd john maxwell and
seth godin as guests on his podcast this
was such a great insight that he gave so
let's jump into today's featured content
[Music]
carrie i want to drive a little bit
deeper on your secrets
for
highly productive content creators
here's one of the things that impresses
me
about you um first of all again not not
meant to say from flattery or because
you're on the podcast or because this
book you know has so been so profoundly
impactful but i read a ton of books like
i really i actually read a lot i'm
excited lately i'm reading about three
books a week right now
blessed to be able to kind of have that
momentum going um and and i just love
books and i also love the process as an
author myself youtube secrets is that
like 80 000 copies sold or something and
i wrote a couple
not great books youtube for churches was
all right ebook only and i've helped
others write books and so i'm just kind
of obsessed with the process one of the
things i love about it is this book's
actually
really good not just the content is good
but it's also like a really
good book the frameworks are thought
through it's well written it's like the
perfect length 200 pages but then when i
read the outro too it was also
impressive to see all the people that
helped or spoke into it or reviewed the
manuscript but then i'm like okay so not
only this but i also read your book
didn't see it coming
amazing book as well and then i think
about okay you have this podcast and
it's just been consistent you've been
doing it for years and you're blogging
you've been doing it for years and it
makes me think of this word prolific
you've consistently
created quality content
over
multiple years
and i think that is one of the big
challenges for us as content creators in
general and also youtube creators it's
one thing to start doing a weekly video
it's another thing to do it for a couple
years
and so i want to dive into your six your
secret specifically for content creators
and not everyone maybe wants to write a
book but it's kind of the principles are
the same if you're going to write and
outline a strong youtube video it could
be a 4 or it could be a 10 and you've
really carved that out
let's start with when you started
creating content like for those maybe
two that maybe think they think
i didn't start early enough or whatever
like how about for you like what this
this journey of shifting from leading
being a pastor of a church and really
not writing or being a podcaster when
did you start creating content what's
kind of been your content creation
journey i got serious about it about a
decade ago so you know it's not too late
i started probably in 2012 and that's
because i wrote a book that year called
leading change without losing it which i
think is still out there and i kind of
realized publishers don't sell books
authors do so i read michael hyatt's
platform
and blogging was still a thing believe
it or not it's still a thing um we have
more traffic every year on it if you
know how to do it and i thought okay i'm
going to start blogging and what i did
the the the transferable principle
is i call it a content well so if you
think of a well a well that holds water
you've got content wells that are really
shallow and content wells that are
really deep
so being a pastor by training like you
sean i thought oh i'll probably write
about spiritual growth and i got like a
couple of posts into it and i'm like
this is a really shallow well now i'm a
christian
i'm a pastor but i felt like that's for
sunday okay that's not that's not what i
do for leaders and there's lots of
pastors who do that that's great that's
not me and then i thought well i've been
a communicator my whole life i'm going
to write lots about communication and
then i realized
i got 10 posts on communication like
there's my tricks right that's what i
got but when it came to three subjects
leadership which is pretty broad change
and personal growth
and this is a personal growth look
i still can't find the bottom of the
well and chances are you have
a like you know i would say probably for
you sean one of your content wells is
how to
do youtube how to do video right like
that's like oh it's changing all the
time i could what can you get up and
write about film about talk about day
after day and it's effortless for some
people it's food it's like you love
being in the kitchen i've like five
go-to recipes that's all i got really
shallow content well other people like
every day they're chopping something new
they're trying something new so find
your content well because if you can do
that and it's a deep one then that's
half the problem second thing
is find a template
there's got to be a template that you
use so my blog has a template i'll give
it to you it's super simple and again
you're like blogging that's so 2012. we
had 7 million page views last year so i
wouldn't pronounce it dead yet and it
keeps growing year after year template
for my blog for an article that i write
is
state a problem that the reader is
facing
explain why that's a real issue what's
at stake make it a little bit worse
agitate a little bit and then go into
the solution solutions are bullet
pointed one two three one two three four
five one two three four five six seven
here's seven insights whatever five
three pick your number boom boom boom a
little bit on each and then you wrap up
that's the template believe it or not
it's been working for over a decade and
attracting a bigger and bigger audience
my podcast is long form
and so it's let the guests do the work
let the guests talk i do a brief intro
extra i try to line up great guests sean
you've been a guest try to line up
people consequence on the podcast that's
what i do and then for my videos i'm
less of a video guy by nature but if i
do it tends to be repurposed content or
shorts from some of the other work that
i'm doing so you want to think about a
template because then you don't have to
think about reinventing the wheel all
the time the other thing you want to do
is market test your template and so i
noticed that when i write in that blog
template it goes really well when i
variate fewer people read when i do long
form content on my podcast using the
template that i've created
it just
gets momentum every month it just keeps
growing
so that's led to i think 46 million page
views over the last decade
and uh about 21 million downloads now on
the podcast so you know that template
makes it easy because i'm not
reinventing it and yeah every year or
two you think is this really working or
not maybe you make some tweaks but that
way you just get up and you you pull
from that content well put it in the
template and away you go
that was a rich portion of uh coaching
there carrie and i think what's
fascinating is in a lot of ways the
template you just shared can be a
template for a youtube video outline as
well
absolutely a problem in this video
you'll learn five things that or have
you ever been frustrated by this
particular thing you know this is a big
deal and agitating it it's actually
worse than you think and so let's talk
about the solutions and so uh that's so
powerful and i want to dig a little bit
deeper um
because one of your most influential
assets is your video podcast
i love that in the book you also talked
about um the fact that
you can do this in your yellow zone
because you leverage the power of
interviews as well because they're doing
the heavy lifting you've of course came
up with good questions but you can you
could create those powerful video
podcasts um and i think it was when we
originally talked to i i you hadn't
started your video podcast because but
you you had recorded all the
conversations because you wanted to look
at people on zoom or or whatever and i
was like gary
it is irresponsible for you to to not
have just at least upload even if you
didn't title these well even like
like you might as well just give people
access to all these incredible
conversations you've had but what i love
about it is youtube is not your primary
platform but simply by starting an
interview show
interview podcast
you have
leveraged the power of also putting
those videos out there and i was just
checking out your channel and you know
some of them have over 70 000 views and
you've got thousands of subscribers and
that's kind of like not even the main
thing it's kind of a secondary thing but
i'm curious about this
uh
when it comes to social media what is
your strategy and cadence for creating
and distributing your content across
platforms yeah so on youtube you're
right and you were uh one of the key
catalysts to getting us on youtube and
it was just we had this stuff in the
archive we were ripping the audio so we
started putting it up and now uh i think
2022 is going to be a year where we put
more energy into our video presence
online
but the cadence tends to be more regular
than you think so right now on insta
we'll share one post a day on the main
feed and then a few stories probably you
know anywhere from half a dozen to a
dozen stories
and then we'll also do some reels from
time to time often repurposing content
that we're shooting like this for my
podcaster sometimes i'll go direct to
camera with a message
twitter believe it or not leaders are on
twitter so are people who love politics
we're not so much into the politics but
we're into the leadership thing so we'll
post uh seven to ten times a day just
little excerpts tweets thoughts sound
bites on twitter facebook a very similar
thing one of the things that's given us
a lot of traction lately and my social
media person carly is amazing at this
she just asked really great questions
like
what did seminary not prepare you for
let us know there's no like fancy
graphic or whatever i think we're 300
comments and counting on that one and
then you save it
you go back in there because people told
you what they're struggling with now
you've got blog content and and video
content for the future so sometimes
simple questions we're a little bit on
linkedin and a few other platforms but
those are the major foci for us
that's powerful and uh right now how
much you know with someone listening to
that i'm curious kind of two-prong
question what is the
how is it these responsibilities
delegated to your team
but what advice would you give to
somebody if you were starting over
and you're still a full-time pastor
um
or you're still an attorney and that's
that's where you're anchored but you
want to start moving online
um and so you're by yourself
right and you're going to tackle a
platform would you try to be on all the
social media platforms
as a solo side in a solo side hustle
season um and so see maybe speak to that
first and then obviously where you are
today well your business model
everything it makes sense to have a team
around you so let's speak what advice
would you like started for me i mean i
was solo it was a hobby man so i didn't
have a team i was the team and i picked
that this is again a decade ago just
twitter facebook and later instagram as
it sort of went into the mainstream and
i started doing that and you know you've
got i don't know exactly what our team
uses right now because they handle all
the scheduled stuff but you know buffer
and other
schedulers like that can really help you
you can do effective social media in
under 20 minutes a day you sort of get
your thoughts ready put them into some
kind of social media scheduling thing
and then you just release them at
strategic points over the day uh on a
break later in the day just go on your
phone you see who's interacting who's
engaging who's not make a couple of
responses a couple of likes couple of
favorites it doesn't have to be
overwhelming so that's where i would
start and as to which platform here's
what i would do
which one is most native to you my guess
is we got a lot of videographers here
you know a lot of people who love videos
so probably is youtube and tick tock
maybe or instagram reels that would be
natural the other question to ask though
is where's your audience like if you
have an avatar where are they are they
on tick tock are they on instagram are
they on linkedin you know linkedin gets
overlooked if you want to reach young
men in business and corporate linkedin
gets overlooked all the time i spoke at
south by southwest a couple of years ago
every young entrepreneur i met from
silicon valley austin places like that
they're like okay let's connect on
linkedin like that is just where people
are at so ask where your audience is at
what's natural for you and then use the
scheduling service to uh to set that up
and you'll save some time
brilliant now one of my
questions after i'm a listener of your
podcast and we'll link that up as well
uh i think that
uh when the leader grows
everybody grows that's not your quote
that's probably craig's it's
he's the author of most quotes so right
uh yeah but but ultimately that even
maybe you're listening to this you don't
consider yourself a leader man if you
listen to leadership content you grow as
a leader you will be better at youtube
you'll be better in your family you'll
be better in life and i think it's
what's needed because as youtube
creators a lot of us are starting we're
kind of like accidental entrepreneurs
and we haven't had much leadership
training no and so
uh definitely check out uh carrie's
podcast but what's kind of crazy about
your podcast if you've is you have high
profile guests
so you've had simon sinek and rick
warren and mike todd john maxwell seth
godin you've also had ceos of
organizations and celebrities and
different people on your on your podcast
i'm just kind of curious your advice for
anybody that would aspire to have high
profile guests like how did you kind of
build that momentum out for your podcast
when it comes to some of those more high
profile people
timely question i was working on a
resource on exactly that today sean for
leaders so
um you're not gonna probably start by
landing landing adam grant or people
like that they're extremely busy and if
you're holding out for that
good luck so what i would do and this is
what i did i started with the people i
know your friends like who are the
people who will text me back right who
are the people who will answer my email
and fortunately for me i had known andy
stanley for the better part of a decade
when i launched my podcast and so it was
a big ask but i felt reasonably
comfortable asking andy and went through
the appropriate channels and he agreed
to be guest number one so that was great
so who in your immediate network has the
most influence where you could possibly
get her or him to be guest number one
and then what you want to do is continue
to ship your show and you just
deal with the leaders that you want to
deal with and you talk to them and you
get your friends to be on the show and
again you know you got to think is this
going to serve the audience
but you do that and then you'll start to
build up downloads and then it's like
wow we have 10 000 downloads or you know
we got 100 000 views or whatever it is
and then what you could do is you could
take your your library of guests your
best known guests and your stats and you
can start to cold call people and say
hey i've done 25 episodes because i'll
the reason a lot of people even if they
know you will not kick off your show is
podcasts in particular and i'm sure
there are lots of youtube channels like
this as well
everybody starts off big and then eight
episodes in it's they're in the
graveyard and so nobody wants to take
like a busy person does not want to take
an hour of their day to do your show
that you are not going to have the
discipline to continue eight episodes in
so um now that you've got 20 episodes or
whatever you can say hey sean i'd love
to have you on my podcast i've also had
this youtuber i've had this person try
to find out who their friends are and
say we've also got 100 000 views you
know 20 000 downloads whatever that
happens to be
would you be open to it let them know
you know their work and then say either
way i'm going to remain a fan really
appreciate you sean thanks so much
carrie and you kind of go from that and
so like i just um do i have the book
here now it's upstairs 4 000 weeks i
started reading that book by oliver
berkman i thought man it'd be great to
get him emails are really easy to find
on the internet believe it or not
and so i just emailed him and told him i
loved his book i respected work i'm also
an author in the space listed all of his
friends because i googled him that i've
interviewed and remember treat your
guests well because if he's friends with
adam grant and seth godin and malcolm
gladwell and simon sinek they all talk
and it's like who's this carrie guy i
don't know this carry guy and it's like
oh don't go near his show he's a
deadbeat right that's
you get a reputation so you want to
treat all of your alumni well
and uh fortunately oliver said yes he
had actually bought my book at your best
a month to the day before i emailed him
so he's like this must be a thing we
have to do it so we're going to connect
and and do the show or you know ramit
sethi who's a huge online marketer i've
cold called him a couple times he
finally said yes to be on the show but
i'm like i bought your courses uh i love
your work i've been a student for years
here are some of your friends don't say
here are your friends but my guests have
included and and that's a way of cold
calling and believe it or not we all do
it because
we're all connected to some people but
there are some people we don't know so
you're you're gonna have to get in the
habit of cold calling and respecting
them knowing they're busy i'll often put
in the email i know you get a hundred of
these a week i can understand if you
don't have time no worries but i'd love
to have you on the show and
often believe it or not the majority of
times it works
killer advice from carrie
newhoff i can uh so grateful for
everything you've been sharing today and
these
secrets of highly productive content
creators
hey think media podcast i highly
recommend you pick up a copy of at your
best um again at think media this year
you could even check out our series you
know carrie we are doing a four part so
we're having through it uh at our best
as a team and we're talking about our
themes are at our best in terms of
wellness and that's really kind of like
the heart of this being in that green
zone at our best in terms of
productivity you hit that as well and in
terms of mastery and excellence at our
best in terms of service and our
community and then at our best in terms
of our mission and really being mission
and purpose driven uh a team and so
we're devoting a year to this and i just
want to really thank you and honor you
for
putting so much love into this book
and so much excellence into the book
it's really a blessing to our team and
want to give you a chance of course to
shout out where can people connect with
you follow you anything else
that you would love the think media
podcast community to take action on this
would be your chance to shout that out
well i just want to let you know i'm
very humbled that you would do that when
you reached out to me and let me know
that was happening that there's there's
no greater
joy for an author or content creator to
see that their work is making a
difference so you really um humbled me
with that sean and i'm i'm grateful and
excited to see what's next for you and
the team at think media you can find the
book anywhere books are sold you can
also go to at yourbesttoday.com
and then i'm an easy google i got a
weird name
and we started something new called the
art of leadership academy
i went to law school never learned how
to run a law firm went to seminary no
one taught me how to run a church so
we're trying to help leaders with the
soft and hard skills of leadership over
at the art of leadershipacademy.com
man i love it carrie thanks again for
coming on the show thank you thanks for
having me sean
well i hope that you enjoyed that
interview and it was such a privilege to
have carrie newhalf in there talking to
our entire leadership team here at think
media everyone is a leader so it was
such a great experience to be able to
have him uh as part of what we're doing
here at think and have his influence as
what we are bringing into the podcast
again i'll make sure to post all of the
links down below if you're watching on
youtube and you want to go to a previous
episode or if you are listening on audio
it'll be available for you in the show
notes wherever you're listening to audio
on and i'll make sure to link up
carrie's book at your best and check out
all of his books carrie is such a
fabulous author and is really someone
who has leveled me up as a leader um and
as someone who is wanting to be at my
best throughout this whole year i
actually have to credit to carrie
newhoff for helping me change some of my
own daily habits so that i could be at
my best not just for what i'm doing at
think media but so i could be at my best
for myself my husband and my kids um and
that i could really be living my best
life so i'm so grateful for his
influence in what we're doing here at
think media you could actually say thank
you to carrie if you'd like to over on
social media by taking a screenshot of
this on your phone tagging him on social
media and make sure to tag us as well uh
at miss heather torres or at official
think media well thank you so much for
being a part of what we're doing and
every single week we'd love to shout out
one of our think media community members
who has raided and reviewed the podcast
for us today it comes from mr b paz says
love this show love this podcast and
everything about think media it has
definitely helped me choose media
products taught me about software setups
and ultimately inspired me to get in
front of my camera and just hit record
ah is that not the message we love to
preach just hit record i'm so grateful
that you are part of our community and
that this podcast is impacting you on a
level that's going to help you get
outside your comfort zone and actually
press record well thank you for
listening to today's episode make sure
you subscribe wherever you're listening
to this podcast on and we'll catch you
in next week's episode bye
[Music]
you